hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we are talking about the skills
you
need to be a successful software
engineer that
aren't technical so what are they
number one organization
y'all the amount of
time people can save by truly being very
organized in their coding is pretty
insane especially when you're working
with a team
and you are able to be that team member
who
gives that next person very nice clean
code imagine just going about your day
and then
you are handed a project and it's just
haywire
in the files functions go are everywhere
variables all these things are just
everywhere imagine how much harder your
day
now is because the person before you who
had this project
did not organize their things well
so that is why it's very very important
because it can save you
loads of time for not only yourself but
for your whole team and make sure
that you if you don't have
organizational skills
you practice it now during your coding
you can do this by making sure that
your functions are grouped in a way that
makes sense by making sure that
your functions aren't also you know 20
lines long but
you have you know very short concise
functions for
each different operation being done by
doing these little things you
really can really positively affect the
trajectory
of your project so make sure you
practice that
today number two you need to be
very very very detail-oriented
the amount of times i have spent
hours just going through my code now
understanding why it's not working why
i'm getting this
error on my browser every time i try to
run my code and see that it's because
i had a comma somewhere that it wasn't
supposed to be or i had
an extra number somewhere x y and z it's
ridiculous and so where does being
detail oriented come in
well not necessarily for what you would
think
for not creating those errors but for
finding
them when they occur if you're able to
really clearly go through things with a
fine-tooth comb
that's gonna be great for error handling
because errors are gonna happen and so
this isn't even about like oh you won't
like get these errors like and
you know by being detail-oriented either
you will you know
contract less errors but it's really
more for
once the errors come you are able to
really swiftly
go through your code with this
fine-tooth comb and find
boom there's a comma and then taking it
out and then boom
your code works your project is up and
it's ready to launch
and so really making sure that you can
have that
eye and not just peruse through and miss
all these
little tiny little details splattered
all over
you know your code and everything your
files it really really can make
all the difference for you and your team
to practice this
first thing you really need to make sure
to do is
once you get that error look up where
that
error is what line is being spit out at
you as
sorry this line it's not working for us
nothing it's not always right
um the line that your computer says is
the problem
but by being able to first look at that
and then see what type of error
it is and going from there it can very
much
assist in that error handling process
and so really make sure that
you don't just go straight away from oh
my code isn't working too
now let me try to figure out what my
code is and changing all these things
without ever looking at where your
computer says your code is
and why your code is so really make sure
you practice those things
next you need to be a problem solver
there are a bajillion one ways to
produce the same exact thing when it
comes to code
think of it this way there are so many
ways to get the number
two to show up you can do one plus one
you can do
three minus one you can do four divided
by two
same with your coding there are so many
ways to get the same answer to get the
same result to get the same thing to pop
up so you need to be able to when
something doesn't work
be able to say okay let's try this way
and then that doesn't work okay
let's try it this way and just being
able to
fix your mind in a certain way where it
can think of things in
completely different ways and figure out
different approaches to a problem
in order to get the answer is pertinent
to the role seriously
it is so so so so important being able
to think creatively in order to
find the right approach be a problem
solver and
really just look at this as a puzzle
that you need to just
put together it really really will
assist
in the whole development process seeing
this as more of a puzzle
rather than you know you not being able
to get the answer
and so yeah be a problem solver
and so that actually goes into our next
point
which is be patient be patient
specifically
with yourself think of it more like i
just said
less about ah i just i'm just so bad at
this and
you know i can't do x y and z like no
you are just a person
trying to solve a puzzle and so when you
are faced with a 500 piece you know
jigsaw puzzle and all you don't beat
yourself
up saying oh i'm so stupid or oh i just
am not right for this
just because pieces aren't fitting
because you know
the working piece is in there somewhere
and so think of this the same way like
okay this did not work that is okay we
have all of these other pieces that we
can try to make it work
i just need to get there and so making
sure that you're patient with yourself
and are really maintaining that positive
attitude
will seriously get you farther in this
process in this journey because you are
not you know putting yourself down you
don't
like who would want to go to a job that
they constantly felt stupid that they
constantly felt like they weren't good
enough
like you don't want that for yourself
you want to be able to go to a job
which you say today we're going to you
know solve x y and z and we're going to
figure out different ways to do it
and come back home and do it all the
next day and so yeah
be patient with yourself know that this
at the end of the day they're all just
puzzles
and you will find the matching piece at
some
moment the next thing that you need to
be
able to do is know how to ask the right
question it is so
so underrated the power of asking the
right
question has it can seriously be the
difference
from knowing and answering three hours
versus three minutes
let's say you're stuck on creating you
know a navigation
bar for your web app asking a question
like how do i write a line
my nav bar while keeping the list items
in line that's a much better question
than how do i make sure that
the words in the nav bar stick together
it is so important to be able to ask the
right questions
so that the people around you know
exactly
what you are looking for and can provide
you with the right
answer people just expect software
engineers to be these people who just
spend eight hours a day just coding
things out and then go home
so much time is spent asking questions
however
the difference between being the most
liked person on the team to the
least liked person is knowing the
questions to
ask you need to make sure that the
questions you ask aren't wasting your
time
other people's time and are really
really targeting the issue at hand
and so know how to really zone
in on the problem and ask the correct
question whether it be to your manager
to google et cetera both of them are
able to help you
but help them help you now this last
skill that you all need to have is being
able to obtain
a future mindset in your coding so what
does this mean
i like to describe it as developing for
the future
coding for the future where i will code
now a certain way
knowing that i'm going to be using this
function to give me a certain result
and that result is going to determine x
y and z and so i need to make sure
i account for certain inputs for certain
variables for certain
you know numbers if they if there's a
possibility
of numbers being negative or a decimal
and accounting for that
in my code now of course this takes
practice and it takes a lot of foresight
but it's something that can really limit
the amount of times you have to go back
and edit previous code because
oh i didn't realize you know there's a
possibility of a negative number
happening so let me make sure i
account for that in my code or oh i
didn't realize x y and z so let me go
back here
it can really limit that by being able
to think a few steps ahead at
what the end goal is and how all the
ways
a user can use your functions or the
functions can work
and being able to account for that now
in your development
it's something that yeah is truly truly
truly can make all the difference
and like i said it takes practice but
practice it now there are ways you can
practice that
now by saying okay if you know if the
number's positive do this but
if the number is negative do this having
if statements having try catch
statements
really being able to account for the
different scenarios that can come up
in the future that's really how you do
that
and so everybody i hope some of y'all
have been able to see certain skills
that
it's like okay you know what i really do
need to hone in on my organization i
really need to
hone in on you know being detail
oriented i hope this has done that for
you if it has
please let me know by liking below and
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
i love seeing this community grow and i
really just appreciate it when you all
support
me and my channel and yeah don't forget
to follow me on instagram at the black
female engineer
and i will see y'all later bye y'all